there is um
more and more information
coming out
about a black man
who was awaiting a kidney transplant who
was beaten by hospital security
the man has sadly died
but we are going to tell you the story
black man awaiting kidney transplant
beaten by hospital security
the daughter of a late black kidney
patient wants justice against the
security guards who attacked and wrongly
detained him according to the st louis
post dispatch
the shocking incident begins with huey
robinson heading back to the barnes
jewish hospital in st louis after staff
told him he left his wallet there a few
days before the patient who had stage
four renal failure got the good news he
was number two in line for a possible
kidney transplant he got his wallet he
went back to the garage and he couldn't
find his car
so he goes to the front desk he uh
and even a security asks a security
guard for help as he looks for his car
apparently this caught the attention of
other security guards who started
suspecting this guy's not here for
medical treatment this guy is here
looking to steal cars
guards approach robinson they grab his
arm
and
he re then allegedly asks what did i do
one of the guards tackles him and then
uh it all gets crazy and he gets the
crap kicked out of him and subsequently
he died it's an insane story there is
indeed surveillance footage and in the
surveillance footage you see
um a number of uh
security officers come over
and very quickly the physical
altercation begins we don't know what
was being said there
uh a third security guard comes in
they've got him pinned to the ground
and chaos ensues uh quite quickly
chaos ensues quite quickly
and he was looking for his car
he had just gotten the good news he's
second in line for a kidney transplant
and this is what happens we don't have
all of the answers yet i guess we would
say
the lawsuit alleges that huey cried out
that the guards were hurting him and at
least one of the guards responded good
according to the lawsuit the guards then
forced huey into a pair of handcuffs
it's all on video you just saw the
document says that robinson was taken to
an interrogation room he was asked what
are you doing in the garage
the lawsuit also claims an officer used
his forearm to smash huey's head into
the wall while another threatened the
kidney patient
if one of my officers or wash you
officer sees you back on this property
again we're gonna do this whole thing
again they told them because you ain't
supposed to be here
he had just been at the hospital for
four days
for treatment
for kidney problems
he was drugged in a weakened state when
security allegedly beat him up then
there was a lawsuit for assault battery
false imprisonment he later died from
his illness and his daughter wants
justice
so
there are people saying well why are you
even mentioning that it's a black man
we're mentioning it because it's yet
another one of these stories where i'll
tell you guys if you tell me uh it
it was it was a white guy looking around
and saying hey uh i'm looking for my car
uh i just don't believe that three
security guards show up suspecting that
the guy is looking to steal cars i just
don't think so i just don't believe it
and i know that there's a movement on
the right that loves to say oh david
you're racist for seeing the racism
no i don't think so
i mean when when you see these stories
and it goes beyond anecdotal and it
becomes the trend it becomes the way
they go
and we featured others
it no longer is anecdotal and so that's
why the story is being described in the
way that it's being described and sadly
this man ultimately died not from
getting beat up but from his illness
we'll see where the lawsuit goes if you
look at the video if you read the story
if you look at the facts and come to
understand it differently
let me know i want to hear from you